nous avec jean-françois timsit chef du
service réanimation médicale et
infectieuse à l'hôpital bichat bonsoir
jean françois timsit merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france on vient de parler des variants
est précisément le conseil scientifique
craint que le variant brésilien
deviennent majoritaires cet été est ce
que c'est une hypothèse qui semble
probable selon vous il ya la conjonction
de trois choses qui joue un rôle un peu
inquiétant la première chose c'est que
la circulation du virus en france est
encore extrêmement élevé la deuxième
chose c'est que finalement le variant
anglais comme il a un taux de
reproduction très élevé est certainement
plus élevé que le variant sud-africain
hilarion brésilien finalement ils
contrôlent les choses et comme le vaccin
va être très actif sur ce variant il va
probablement baisser et laisser de la
place pour les autres variantes qui sont
plus virulents mais un petit peu moins
contagieux comme le variant brésilien
vaillance et afrique donc ça c'est la
deuxième point qui fait un peu peur
c'est de voir que finalement comme le
variant brésilien est moins sensible et
moi le vaccin est moins efficace sur ce
variant brésilien invariants sud
africain eh bien on risque d'avoir
proportionnellement une montée de ce
type de variants par rapport aux
variants anglais qui a pris le dessus à
l'heure actuelle vous justement en tant
que médecin les mesures prises on en a
parlé avec estelle farges les
quarantaines les pcr ou obligatoire avec
disney sanction est ce qu'elles sont
suffisantes ou c'est déjà trop tard
il était temps en tout cas il est clair
que du fait de la liberté individuelle
française et ce respect il ya eu
probablement assez tôt de coercition
taj est bien fait il ya beaucoup de
tests disponibles mais le tracking était
vraiment trop basé sur le volontariat et
l'isolément était aussi trop basé sur le
volontariat d'où je pense que par le
biais de la carte sanitaire on va
pouvoir probablement mieux tracé et
j'espère mieux isoler les cas et en
particulier ceux liés aux variants
brésiliens ou variante sud afrique par
exemple au royaume uni on a appris
aujourd'hui on va interdire aux
voyageurs venus d'inde où il ya un
variant dangereux aussi d'entrer tout
simplement sur son territoire ce sont
des mesures fermes mais c'est ce qu'il
faudrait qu'on fasse également nous en
france et accessoirement l'europe
le problème c'est que les virus il se
fiche complètement des frontières et que
s'il n'ya pas d'attitude mondiale autour
de ce contrôle de variants bas il
rentrera par un autre pays il y aura
toujours un pays où l'attitude sera plus
libre plus libéral et fera que le vario
passera par ailleurs on parle pas de
pays amis comme le portugal par exemple
où les liens entre le brésil et le
portugal sont importants heureusement
l'épidémie est faible au portugal mais
on peut imaginer que ce type de variants
puisse venir par par les pays qui parle
le portugais en europe donc voila tout
tout tout est un problème je pense que
en globalité
il est important de mieux tracer et de
mieux isoler les gens et de fournir les
capacités voir les capacités
d'hôtellerie nécessaire à ce que les
gens s'isole mieux alors c'est vrai
c'est particulièrement vrai pour les
nouveaux variants comme le mario
brésilien qui inquiète un peu mais c'est
aussi vrai pour l'ensemble l'épidémie
clairement tout le monde a le regard
tourné vers la début mélanie mais on
nous parle de réouverture vous pensez
que c'est quelque chose de crédible en
tout cas de souhaitable en tant que
médecin cette voie là cette libération
et qui peut à très attendue par les
français au début mais du point de vue
strictement sanitaire je suis quand même
très très inquiet quand on voit le
niveau de circulation virale malgré
quinze jours d'une attitude qu'on peut
appeler d'un confinement modeste et de
fermeture des écoles
j'ai du mal à croire qu'on atteigne un
niveau de circulation virale
suffisamment bas et un niveau de
vaccination suffisamment haut pour qu'on
puisse ouvrir largement qu'il y ait les
petites tentatives très localisées
d'ouverture de certaines petites choses
oui à croire qu'on va pouvoir tout
réouvriront mais honnêtement je pense
que ça serait prématuré et certainement
assez longerons vous sur le terrain à
l'hôpital bichat
quelle est la situation par exemple le
niveau de saturation est maximale nous
avons à l'heure actuelle saturé
l'ensemble elie positif pour les
corvidés aussi beaucoup de malades qui
n'ont pas la cote vide qui soit aussi
hospitalisée et à l'heure actuelle on
est vraiment absolument au niveau
maximal ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
les malades sont très jeunes et quand
ils nécessitent de la réanimation en
particulier ils ont besoin de
ventilation mécanique ils ont besoin de
circulation extracorporelle pour
oxygéner le sens et leur durée de séjour
est de l'ordre de 4 à 5 semaines dans
ces cas là et donc à malade va occuper
50 40 à 50 journées d'hospitalisation en
soins critiques ce qui est considérable
c'est ce qu'on voit ici sur cette photo
qui apparaît à l'écran c'est circulation
extracorporelle et donc ça c'est
vraiment un grave problème parce que
c'est des gens qui sont très jeunes
on va pouvoir tirer de là mais pour
lequel il va falloir plus d'un mois de
réanimation agressive jeu seulement plus
de 30000 contamination par jour c'est
beaucoup le virus circule évidemment
beaucoup trop l'école elle elle pas
reprendre
dans une semaine quel est votre
sentiment là-dessus il ya deux choses
que je pense il faudrait faire et très
rapidement d'une part vacciner
l'ensemble du personnel
il faut savoir que les enfants
transmettre mais sont pas mal mais par
contre ils transmettent aux personnels
qui peuvent être malades et à son tour
transmettre
donc si on pouvait déjà racks il est où
le personnel et des écoles ça serait une
bonne chose
la deuxième chose qui est proposée par
le conseil scientifique depuis très
longtemps c'est d'assurer la circulation
de l'air dans les classes avec des
détecteurs de co2 qui permettent d'avoir
une bonne circulation de l'air si on
calcule bien et tout ce qui avait été
proposé là dessus depuis plusieurs mois
n'a pas encore été mis en place
je pense que ça manque cruellement avec
cette rentrée scolaire qui va être un
test tout à fait clés sur l'évolution de
l'épidémie en france
clairement d'auteur timsit on a un
sentiment toujours de courir après le
train est de ne jamais anticiper les
choses
j'imagine que c'est certainement votre
sentiment sur sur le terrain vous le
voulez attribuer à quoi cette cette
lourdeur administrative que vous
rencontrez peut-être dans les hôpitaux à
la prise de décision au niveau du
gouvernement vous avez une explication
vaud je pense qu'au niveau stricte
sommes strictement sanitaire je vous ai
dit ce qu'il en était effectivement on
aurait besoin de beaucoup plus que ça
après il ya tout un tas d'autres choses
pour lequel je suis pas compétent le
commerce e
l'activité économique actuelle du pays
le déficit
moi je ne suis pas compétent là dessus
donc je ne vais pas à donner mon avis là
dessus strictement sanitairement parlant
je pense qu'il faudrait un confinement
mieux respectés qu'à l'heure actuelle
une sortie d'école très progressive avec
des mesures relativement coercitives une
carte sanitaire très incite à qui si
elle n'est pas coercitive pour arriver à
baisser les taux d'incidence dans le
pays à quatre cinq mille comme on nous
l'avait rapporté en septembre octobre de
façon à pouvoir ré ouvrir
progressivement à 30000 je vois pas bien
comment on va s'en sortir
merci jean françois timsit chef du
service réanimation médicale et
infectieuse à l'hôpital bichat paris
merci d'avoir été avec nous